what was it like getting called to do
jackass it was actually amazing but
scary at the same time but who called
you would they say well I think it was
Shawna that hit me up she hit me up and
she was like Hey we're filming a new
movie and you might want to have you
come hang out with us and I was like
yeah I'm like sounds like an amazing
opportunity but
they be doing some [__] this you know a
little bit above my pay rate yeah
craziness and I was just like all right
I'm down 100 but let's just hope that I
don't lose a neck or anything make it
home safe but yeah it was great it was
amazing everybody was cool from the
staff to meeting everybody I already
knew so many people before so yeah it
felt like like a mini home is it is it
like when you're filling out the
paperwork if I was like dude I I
definitely don't want to do
claustrophobic stuff is that for sure
I'm doing claustrophobic stuff yeah you
can't be forced to do anything like they
well that's not true
you can they might set up a thing where
you like fall through a trap door that
you know and then you're trapped in in
some claustrophobic thing so yeah like
that though they might spring a prank on
you that forces you into a situation
that you're not comfortable with and
that sucks and that probably would
definitely definitely happened did you
have anything like that on your
paperwork like I don't want to do knock
I learned early from Jeff that you don't
tell them what you don't like you only
tell them what you do like anything you
don't like they're gonna get you with
right yeah bringing part of Silence to
the Lambs uh no because see Jeff asked
me what was I cool with trying to take
the uh because he told me at first it
was a snake uh the head of the cookie
was I down to do and I was like [__] it
I'll try it and I guess you took that as
like Ah that's not bring them around the
steak then because he's cool with trying
it
I'm kind of sad I wasn't in that one
like that [__] was that she was
hilarious my dumbass talking about yeah
I'll take the cookie off the snake yeah
what about what about your dad he had to
go through the same paperwork to do some
of the stuff like he interviewed him and
he he [__] up early
I don't like that I'm just like you are
a fool so you look at my interview
versus he is he's like he tells what
he's scared of and I'm like I hate [__]
yeah stand really good week
throw up when I see it
that's so funny dude yeah I already knew
Jeff already he already got plans of
[__] with you you gotta you don't
show with what gets you either like
something comes up don't don't Flinch
just act normal because then they see a
little bit of something they're gonna
run with that [__] that is so funny man
yeah like other than the Bulls and the
sunflower thing which universally nobody
wanted anything to do with I don't think
that there was anything Jasper wasn't
100 game before you know I was just
decided to say I wouldn't say no to
anything and I feel like Shawn and Jeff
kind of know me and if like there's
certain things they probably wouldn't
even work with me that was like we ain't
even gonna ask no problem because we
already know that guy but yeah I was
willing to try everything like at some
point you never got uh the pig semen
dumped on you no they didn't get me with
that one yeah I got I saw somebody get
hit with it
that's one that they wouldn't bother
wasting the pigs even on me
this doesn't phase me
I'm pretty good like that like I
established early on that uh that I'm
just down I remember in the very
beginning of uh very beginning of
Jackass
um
one of the first emails I ever even sent
um I was like hey I got an idea like
um
I want you to hang me upside down from a
tree and torture me for like
that's what you said something like that
okay
something like just absolutely absurd I
think I think and there was a a distinct
motivation for it where I had just been
like partying for like so many days
straight
and like then like a bunch of like pills
or something to like go to sleep and
then when I finally did fall asleep
nobody could wake me up I'm like dude
I'm like man dudes I just parted for
this you know so like nobody could wake
me up like when I'm in that state I want
to be hung upside down from a change too
but do whatever
you know
and they're like yeah
that got me out of a lot of stuff yeah
for sure do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and good news is Stevo's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude